[Music]
well we begin with breaking news out of
Yemen where the Houthi rebels have
released pictures of the assault they
see they conducted inside Saudi Arabia
they claims have captured thousands of
enemy soldiers including Saudi troops a
spokesman said the operation in the
national and region was conducted in
several stages over a number of months
he says at least five hundred fighters
were killed or injured by Canela herd
though buried specialized infantry units
at the frontline cordoned a large number
of the aggressors personnel in Iran as
they managed to set up ambushes as per
the plan our forces opened a way to
allow the aggressor personnel to step
into the ambush specialized units cut
off the rear supply line of the enemy
from the east and the West
after that the cordon was sealed around
this personnel from all sides the
infantry units turned the ambush into an
all-out offensive well earlier speaking
at the UN General Assembly the foreign
minister of Yemen's internationally
backed government blames Iran for the
conflict in his country Tehran has been
accused of arming the rebels Mohamed Al
Hamra man thanks Saudi Arabia for its
role in helping fights the rebels might
be take it easy my leash ugly Iran
exploits the resources of its people in
order to wage war proxy war using
militias capable of the most heinous
forms of destruction in sabotage since
2014 the Houthi militias with support
from Iran have been destroying
everything most beautiful and most
valuable in my country
well the foreign minister also
criticized an ally the United Arab
Emirates for its support of separatists
in southern Yemen da-da-da-da-da-da-da
scary yeah our army has had to face
myriad direct military attacks in
violation of international law these
attacks were mounted by Emirati air
assets these attacks have undermined the
stability of our homeland and in this
way the Emirati aggression has
undermined the noble goals of the
coalition
well Catherine septum is head of Yemen
departments at the peace building think
tank next century foundation and joins
us by Skype from Crawley in the UK oh
good to have you with us on the program
first of all what did you make of this
intimate intervention rather by the
Yemeni foreign minister at the UN
General Assembly I think it was I don't
think it's actually adding to the
conversation I think if anything it's
smudging the waters in terms of the
alliance that sarah has with youí and
other Gulf countries another country
within the region as far as Yemen is
concern and Yemen's war efforts so I
think it was unnecessary and again when
it comes to supporting the secessionist
movements in the south it's very
difficult because you have to ask
yourself the question do you support
political side determination is a
principle of international law or do you
grandstand on the idea of you know every
people having the right to exercise the
democratic rights so I think it's a
debate that needs to take place in you
know for another time okay oddly oh
there are more pressing matters right
now to address
okay I'm sorry to cut you off we
received those pictures earlier so from
Yemen where the Houthi rebels say that
they had captured enemy soldiers within
Saudi Arabian territory they just had a
press conference are waiting to hear
more about that but what do you make of
this claim that the Houthis have
captured thousands of enemy soldiers
including Saudi troops within Saudi
Arabia's territory I think it's more
than a claim I don't think that we have
any reason to actually dispute their
claim and I think that you know the
images and videos coming through
actually affirming the statement and and
this which I find quite interesting is
the fact that not around actually is
part of those territories that have been
you know
disputed by both Yemen and Saudi Arabia
with Yemen claiming that is actually
Yemeni land and if you recall a few
years back at the Malaika Lucy actually
warned a Saudi
that actually continued to bomb him and
an attack him and sovereignty they would
have to redefine where Yemen's border
lie and that they would have to retake
the three southern provinces that the
the Jim there's and that's around I said
and I'm sorry and there's in jizan so
there's an interesting development here
and I think it's a pivot point in this
war when now the Yemeni are directly
moving on Saudi land and therefore have
preached the kingdom sovereignty it's
quite interesting to see that with all
the grand talk of a war coalition Saudi
Arabia is very much alone in this fight
and Washington and other Western capital
for example are nowhere to be seen
coming to aid their ally in in this
direct attack against their
territoriality well what what does this
say in your view about the overall state
of this war you mentioned that the
Saudis are effectively operating alone
in this coalition no one's coming to
their aid do you think the Houthis are
slowly gaining the upper hand in some
areas yes I do I really do and I think
that this war of attrition has actually
worked against Saudi Arabia in this
sense that a lot of the Yemeni now
because of the famine and the immense
hardship that they had to face
notwithstanding the human rights
violation committed by Saudi Arabia have
not rallied around you know the Houthi
and this resistance because they feel
that they're the only entity defending
their land and they right to have a
voice on the international scene it's
quite interesting so now you see that
the Houthis have populated Tim is a de
facto and that they're using this to
actually wield more power and through
their military advances they're actually
gaining even access to more weapon more
territory and essentially pushing the
Saudi against the wall and again the
Saudi have had so far anyway very little
help other than you know country selling
them weapons and quite clearly this is
not you been working in their favor when
it comes to the fact that the Houthi
have planned this attack for month and
month and month then you need to ask
yourself the question where was the you
know the American intelligence I mean
either they did know and didn't do
anything to one side Arabia or did they
didn't know and they need to ask
yourself what it is that did you know
and what is it that they do anyway for
the Saudi so I think it's quite
interesting to see now that
this this attack is actually a people
point in the war and I'm sorry to say
but this how eg I'm not losing on their
ground so it's not just that they lost
the war militarily speaking they
actually lost the territoriality right
now their borders have been breached now
in terms of the the Saudi the saudi-led
coalition we did hear from the the
Yemeni foreign minister at the UN
General Assembly level and criticism at
the UAE who are supposed to be for all
intents and purposes part of this
coalition do you think the saudi-led
coalition is starting to fracture it's
not so much a fracture I think that we
need to be very clear about why the UAE
agreed to enter this whole coalition in
the first place they always made very
clear that the interest was to stabilize
South Yemen because their interest lies
in South Yemen they always wanted to
have yet another waterway you know by
way of out of the support of Aden to
support their own economic interest
which makes complete sense the UE
also wanted to kind of dial down on the
influence that the Muslim Brotherhood
through Aleph law has had in Yemen and
that's why we agreed you know on the
basis that Saudi Arabia would agree she
kind of died back its support of the
Muslim Brotherhood so I don't think that
we should look at towards the UAE and
blame them for anything I think that
what they're doing is what they always
done which is to try to actually wield
soft diplomacy against military
invention because it doesn't work quite
clearly it hasn't worked so I think that
the authority would have to reassess
that position but again it's their
borders that have been breached not the
UAE and the UE did not sign up for you
know losing more of its people in a war
that is clearly a lost one America
however did promise to support surgery
and no matter what and so far we haven't
seen much in terms of help again other
than actually bleeding third year we are
dry of his billions of dollars to buy
further weapons that are not helping on
the ground right now cuz that they fell
actually into the hands of the Houthis
and they will wield them against Saudi
Arabia for sure so there's a there's a
lot of questions that need to be
answered I think okay Catherine Schecter
speak eaters are from Crowley in the UK
thank you very much indeed
if I welcome